welcome to the first session for today
which is dedicated to history and
literature the discussion question for
today is what are the challenges in
research on Brazilian history and
literature in US universities the
elements of attraction and indifference
from American students to exchanges with
Brazilian universities just a word of -
initiate our discussion in 1967 Beija
magazine published a a special issue
with on its cover were historical
figures from Brazil
G Tulio Vargas Don Pedro the first Rory
Barbosa and each of them was speaking
with a balloon but the balloons were in
English and there was a concern that the
Brazilian astir stealing the history of
Brazil writing the history of Brazil
three phrases like independencia Marc
smart you were appearing as independence
and death but the issue was trying to
resolve the problem of what should be
the way Brazilian history and by
implication in Brazilian literature is
viewed should be viewed from the inside
or from the outside and what was the
relative value of the two visions Brazil
has always had visions from the outside
Karl von Maur chioce for example in 1844
wrote a famous essay that won the prize
for the best essay on the history of
Brazil given by the Institute of the
historiography ax and so the question of
the role of view from afar as well as
the role of the view from within has
always been a question for Brazil and
today we have three specialists who will
talk
about that there are areas history and
literature
our first speaker this morning is
Professor Dean Borges associate
professor of history of Romance
languages and literature at the
University of Chicago Dame will initiate
a program and then we will move to the
field of literature Thank You Dean thank
you Thank You Stuart
Mike working yeah
behind me if you're pure at heart you
should be able to see my powerpoint
presentation it's it's Illustrated
there's a flowchart of everything I'm
saying so if I speak too fast just just
follow along with this slide it's people
having problems yeah so talking about
exchanges International Cooperation
structures of cooperation collaboration
is a little bit hard for people in our
disciplines because research tends to be
lone wolf-- solitary research our
articles are single author articles it's
extraordinarily rare and and either a
scandal or delightful that there's a
dual author article if there's an edited
volume it might have two editors or
maybe three but then we find out through
gossip who did all the work we we tend
to have a a sense of individual
accountability for arguments for for
research that's very different from that
in the physical sciences and different
from that in other disciplines of the
social sciences so that when we think of
collaboration we often think of the very
external infrastructure alike bolsa some
we see a fellowships like like library
collections that that we consult but we
we don't think much of let's call them
intermediate
structures so that in associations like
ANBU the association of historians in
Brazil there are working groups group of
travaglio
but those are understood as very loose
coalitions and so we don't expect them
to set an agenda
we rarely expect them to apply for a
collective grant to finance the the
research of the of the scholars of the
individual researchers we instead think
of them more as rooms arenas where we
can have conversations that said we do
depend greatly on the construction of
excellent research facilities and to
give you an example of cooperation that
touches me directly the collaboration
between the bibliothèque nationale and
the center for research libraries in the
United States to microfilm the wonderful
collection of newspapers of the bill
Ithaca Nationale and to deposit a copy
of each of those micro films at the
Center for research libraries which
serves all research libraries in the
United States in theory it will lend
microfilm in practice I think we know
that that can that that that can take
time so something like that arrangement
which fell apart at one point for
frankly personalist reasons a fight
among directors of the programs meant
that after a while the bibliotheca
nacional although it would give you
microfilm if you went to the latekka
Nacional that they would give you
microfilm at cost they were not sending
it to crl directly and so there was a
period of years let me say the 1980s and
1990s when initiative of the of the
educational level hockey library or
archive at the Uni compy the State
University of Campinas to buy micro
films from the vo-tech Nationale and to
make them available in a small reading
room but one which had easier access
than the reading room of the buluttekin
Arsenal for micro films and which
allowed the the digitization the copying
and downloading of newspaper images that
was a tremendous advance and then the
the
wonderful decision about which actually
I don't know the history of the beloved
a canal Nacional to digitalize its
America and to serve it online has
deeply transformed the character of my
research I don't have to go to Rio I
don't have to be first in line at at you
know
7:59 in the morning in order to get a
seat in front of a microfilm reader but
I can read 19th century newspapers late
at night in my in my office at home
and so we rely not so much on
intermediate of research coalition
structures as on great slow investments
in in infrastructure which which which
benefit us another thing which has
benefited scholars in the United States
working on Brazilian history has been
the great expansion and and and the
wonderful quality of the graduate
programs in history especially at the
federal University of Brazil but also at
at at the state universities some Paulo
stands out and at the Catholic
universities and a handful of private
universities the growth of history
education taught by top level
researchers and the cycle in which the
research that a historian does informs
the teaching of undergraduates has
greatly transformed the the quality of
history now you know worldwide there's
been a kind of convergence in higher
education systems the Bologna process in
Europe tried to align the various
university systems of Europe with with
reasonable success the Americanization
of the French style University System of
Brazil has been I think in in general
success and then the decision to make in
history at least the MA a short degree
and the PhD a medium length degree so
that the MA thesis is not a long
published book but rather perhaps a
short intermediate step in in the
research career
this means it's made easier the exchange
of scholars at equivalent levels in
their studies between Brazil and the
United States I can send an MA student
to Brazil and despite their their
relative ignorance they're more or less
at the same stage of their education
similarly a first-year second-year
doctoral student are more or less in the
in the same space so over time the
wonderful quality of the of the doctoral
programs in history in in in Brazil the
growth of libraries at universities like
uni compy I mean I would say that of
those libraries the only County Library
has been my favorite and then the
Mendelian gift to the to the USB library
has has just transformed the library USB
it used to be that to work at us B you'd
had to walk from corridor to library to
library because each department had its
own library collection and so the
centralization of the of the library at
EDSP has had a tremendous I think
accelerating a tremendous feedback
effect on research there in the social
sciences and humanities in in general so
I'm deeply indebted for growth to growth
in infrastructure generally what else
would I mention I'd say the third thing
you know the libraries the
digitalization of of holdings the you
know what do we have left in the Museo
Nacional Benjy gol this meteorite
brought from bhaiyya in of our founding
by in the 1780s
brought to to hill de janeiro in the in
in in the 1880s and it's all that's left
of the Museo Nacional so I'm part of a
digitization preservation project at the
University of Chicago mostly led by
scholars archeologists of the Middle
East who are deeply destroyed by a
distraught at the sacking of libraries
the destruction of archaeological sites
in the in the wars there but deeply
committed to
digital preservation of holdings of all
sorts in all places around the world
if the Museo Nacional had been had had
been thoroughly
digitalized we bemoan the the the the
fire certainly biological specimens
would have been lost but the loss of
language data the loss of ethnic graphic
did everything that we lost in in in in
in that fire would at least in a
diminished form be be be accessible and
so if there were one thing that you know
what do you learn by having a fire in
your house you learn to have copies of
your documents if there were one thing
that I wish that that would happen would
be more extensive digital preservation
of collections in the United States as
well in Brazil
none of the Chicago museums and archives
special collections and libraries is
completely digitally copied and
preserved and of course you copy it and
then you don't have the copy in the
vault of the people that can SNL you
have the copy in five or six different
places around the world that was why the
CRL below deck unless you know microfilm
project the idea was to deposit a set a
complete set of the of the patrimony at
the at the CRL vault so infrastructure
finally another structure which matters
to us lone wolf
individual researchers immensely is
language teaching you can probably be a
good enough field biologist without
speaking Portuguese well you can
probably be a good enough collaborating
geologist and just assume that that your
colleagues will speak English which has
become the kind of diminished Latin
lingua franca around the the world yeah
I mean I ran an MA program 40% of whose
students were from China and they had
learned English because they loved it
maybe maybe because they had to and so
yeah you can you can do certain kinds of
research without good Portuguese but in
our fields especially in
but also in history we need to develop
American American students who who can
speak Portuguese in the United States
Spanish has become the default foreign
language instruction 90% the foreign
language instruction is in is in Spanish
in high schools and secondary schools in
the United States Spanish is pretty much
the only language that's taught and so
if students come to Portuguese they tend
to come to it in in college they tend to
come to it from Spanish and they tend to
like it
enrollments in beginning classes and
Portuguese are very low but there's a
very high rate of conversion from
beginning to intermediate Portuguese in
in in in top American colleges that
means that they when they're exposed to
Brazil they fall in love with Brazil for
better for worse in the wrong way or the
right way they tend to like Brazil and
so they tend to go on to the
intermediate level and as a consequence
many uh there's a higher proportion
let's say who ought to be going then in
doing a study abroad in Brazil and here
we find I'm not a development economists
but I was trained by development
economists there we find a bottleneck
yes the bottleneck is that study abroad
programs in Brazil are few and far
between for a variety of reasons the
reputation of violence is probably the
the greatest one I once had a student
say to me that her parents would not let
her go to Peru because Sendero Luminoso
they would not let her go to to Real de
Janeiro I guess because of the Simpsons
episode about about Rio right they would
not let her go to Mexico because of
drugging they would let her go to
Ecuador why they had never heard of
Ecuador they knew nothing about Ecuador
Ecuador has for I forget the the the
salute you can look them up 4 to 10
times as many American students study
abroad in Ecuador
as study abroad in Brazil now Ecuador is
a wonderful country and some of the
study abroad students have come back
from there with a wonderful education
but I would prefer that they go to
Brazil I would prefer that you know that
that that they went to fetes and Donna
great city like that but study abroad
you know the Brazilian government
tourist promotion has always been
ambivalent and mediocre Brazil has never
really wanted tourists that much and you
compare it to a country like Mexico or
Spain which has active tourist promotion
of course the American students know why
they should be going to Mexico of course
they know what they will find in Spain
the Alhambra but - have they ever heard
of little bit though have they you know
do they have any idea of a place like
San Pablo no so the bottleneck is I
think study abroad because study abroad
converts students from half committed
language learners to little Brazilian
asst
you know these these little Brazilian
assigned graduate programs very few of
them are qualified by their
undergraduate studies to begin a serious
doctoral program in Brazilian history or
or in Brazilian literature were much
more forgiving in in Brazilian history
so will will kind of bring a drop
doctoral student along for a year or two
years or even three years while their
language skills are not great it's maybe
a mistake
we will also the the Fla s the Flass
fellowship system has bribed persuaded
converted students from being students
of Spanish American history to being
students of Brazilian history so Flass
fellowships have helped I myself did not
speak a word of Portuguese until I got a
flass fellowship and I had to take
Portuguese language
I earned my B by going to class but
never going to the language lab I
thought hey I can read much other CS I
can speak this why should I
you know listen then of course I went to
Baia where I spoke Portuguese perfectly
but then when people spoke back to me
you know it's very hard to understand
them and and and I would pick up the
phone in at that time the phone and body
was very young you know on the noisiest
streets in the world and I would say you
know a hustle venir a su archivo and of
course everyone would say yes yes get
off the phone
come here and I will do anything so
language learning in history can be slow
but as says I will talk about this
little bit language learning in to be
ready for Advanced Study in literature
is a more complicated issue so we have a
very small pool of of candidates for
Advanced Study in in our field in the
United States anything that the
Brazilian government could do to foment
study abroad would help us immensely
anything and you know what do Americans
love they love winning a contest even
Tomodachi had a contest where you could
win $200 towards your airfare to go to
Brazil I promise you that would that
would get all of the Americans in this
room have a lottery ticket in their
pocket I'm sure the competition winning
that kind of small stimulus could make a
huge huge difference and so the pool of
eligible candidates for doctoral study
is is very small very self selected and
pre-selected for us history is a little
better at converting people away from
Spanish American toward toward toward
Brazilian studies and so another point
of leverage perhaps for converting
people to two qualifications business
would be ma programs a one-year or
two-year MA program would give American
students more opportunity for for
language study the Wisconsin two-year MA
program does let students
have a philosophy oh ship to study
Portuguese and so they're people I've
known as undergraduates who've done the
MA of Wisconsin and emerged from it as
as as as competent as as competent
Portuguese speakers so foment study
abroad and maybe uh have little
fellowships or make deals with MA
programs that can that can give American
talented American students with a
certain commitment to social sciences or
the humanities or to Latin American
Studies an opportunity to build their to
build their language so I think that
would double the size of the pool of
eligible candidates for Advanced Study
of of Brazil and of course that would
that that that would increase the odds
of having high quality scholars in the
mix I you know I became a Brazilian
estoy aqui dn't I think that's probably
true of most of the people who became
committed to the history of Brazil I
think a few small reduction of
bottlenecks reduction of friction
reforms could could could make a
difference in in in growing the field in
the United States our next speaker is
say cyborg Baraka prenatal professor of
Brazilian Lucia phone African in
comparative literature at Northwestern
University say sir as has been visiting
professor and various places including
Mozambique and he will speak to us about
literature thank you I suppose and we
can
first of all I want to thank professor
David Jackson and the organizers of this
event namely the council of latent
latin-american Liberian studies at the
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at the University and the
Ministry of Education in Brazil and
Gustavo said it in particular more
specifically it is a pleasure and an
honor to be part of this panel panel
next to my best friends even though in
reality I have just met professors
Jewish Schwarz and professors at
Garfield he's an old friend so but but
what I mean to say is that as a scholar
of literary and cultural studies I
consider historians to be my best
friends though those with whom I share a
passion and sometimes in the case of
Brazil a fear for our documents and
precarious archives more moreover if it
is true that we are here because we all
share a general interest in Parra and
perhaps concern for the future of
Brazilian studies in the u.s. we
historians and literature scholars find
ourselves in the middle of an additional
and broader crisis which is this
much-discussed crisis in the humanities
that affects both the US and resident
institutions but we win the prize among
the humanities it is the language and
literature departments there are the
most vulnerable and among these the
foreign languages and among those deep
teaching and research in so-called less
commonly taught languages such as
Portuguese and those are the most
vulnerable of all those who constantly
need to struggle to prove one's
relevance and sometimes one's existence
however I want to avoid as much as
possible
the catastrophic sometimes apocalyptic
tone that has characterized much of the
recent debates on the profession it is
true that it is rather difficult not to
be alarmed or even to panic sometimes
when we consider the present and the
future of the humanities in higher
education in general and in Brazil in
particular a recent piece by Eric hazard
professor of comparative literature at
Penn State University in one of the
publications
of the modern languages associations
gives plenty of evidence of the
dimensions of the crisis we enjoy to
have an idea the article is entitled the
sky is falling
in summary Herick hired calls attention
to the rapid and steady decline of the
tenure track jobs advertised in the MLS
job information list particularly in the
last 10 years or so when the numbers
dropped more than 50 percent let me
point out that in Portuguese this year
is actually not a bad ear we have like
five or six positions for in Portuguese
departments but we can't say that this
is a trend and in five or six is good as
expected this describe this decline in
jobs also corresponds to an overall
decline of 50% in humanities majors at
several institutions after presenting
this dramatic evidence the author
suggests that in order to remain
relevant the only way out for literary
scholars is interdisciplinarity and a
quote we may want to double down on this
interdisciplinarity seeing our courses
as training in the humanities in general
ourselves ourselves as humanists in
general in our work as a reentering our
students to the big human questions
which are after all not constrained by
the boundaries boundaries of the
universities disciplinary divisions and
of course I myself couldn't agree more
although the case of literature's
produced in less commonly taught
languages is always a lot more dramatic
among other reasons because we are
almost always neatly like either on high
level of language proficiency from the
students or the availability of works in
translation in addition the scope and
the viability of the interdisciplinarity
imperative vary according to the nature
or the institutions I should also note
that the nature and the scope of our
research on the one hand and our
teaching on the other or of our
the one hand and our departments on the
other do not always coincide and yet as
scholars of the Zenon literary and
cultural studies we must understand our
research as inherently the
interdisciplinary and our pedagogical
practice needs to be committed to
renewed forms of collaboration the study
Brazilian culture culture in the u.s. at
least on the undergraduate level is very
different from studying it in Brazil of
course indeed for decades courses on
Brazilian literature culture focused on
subjects such as Brazilian popular music
mystery sashing and democracia has Yao
Carnival and other cultural
exceptionalism
but this has changed as we understand
Brazilian culture as part of the world
no matter how complicated this
relationship might be so perhaps because
I was trained as a comparative I think
that should they more than ever
Brazilian cultures is to be understood
transnationally let me illustrate some
of the issues scholars and Brazilian
culture working mostly in Spanish and
Portuguese departments face as they are
really perhaps only two departments in
the West that exclusively Portuguese
departments so let me illustrate this
with my own experience in the two
research universities where I have
taught two institutions which are
nevertheless very different from each
other after finishing my patient in
comparative literature at UC Berkeley my
first teaching position was at Rutgers
University in New Brunswick New Jersey
where I taught for more than ten years
Rutgers like Berkeley is a public
university with one of the most diverse
student populations in the u.s. at the
time again about 20 years ago the field
was starting to change and I can say
that things seemed pretty auspicious for
example I often heard at the time that
there was a clear divide within Spanish
and Portuguese departments that looser
Brazilians were marginalized in
decision-making and they were often
excluded from
graduate teaching and advising sure to
be a chair to chair a spanish and
portuguese department or even should
direct the graduate program was pretty
much unthinkable at the time
moreover someone who had a PhD in
literature many times had to teach
Portuguese and in some case even a
Spanish language but this is not what I
encountered on the contrary at least in
my experience in Spanish and Portuguese
departments welcomed and actually were
enthusiastic about having Brazilian Asst
as their colleagues and in fact I was
asked to teach language a language
course only once in my entire career
after grad school Rodriguez had a very
large Portuguese and a growing Brazilian
student body as there was huge
population of Spanish speakers
therefore enrollments were never
concerned and one could easily teach
classes on Fernando Pessoa machado de
assis gracilis fart-o and always in
Portuguese there was also some support
from the Portuguese foundations and the
Portuguese government which in my view
contrasted with the Brazilian government
institutions which seemed much more
interested in financing programs in the
wealthiest research universities rather
than investing in the growing Brazilian
community in the West the so called
brazuca and I say this because today we
see a growing presence of heritage
students even in the private elite
institutions and this is something worth
paying attention at as it has started to
have a significant effect on teaching
and research on Brazil on the other hand
beyond the department I also noticed a
growing interested in courses taught in
English particularly in the program in
comparative literature which I was
affiliated and soon became the director
of undergraduate studies but also in
other unit is such as African Studies
and Women and Gender Studies a few years
later my department hire a second time
professor well.when until then it was
quite unusual unusual to have more than
one and it's do it but but after the
place of Brazilian studies seem to be
consolidated the financial crisis and
the resulting crisis in the humanities
came about it was also at this time that
both of us professors of Portuguese left
Rutgers and our positions were not
replaced for almost 10 years Rutgers New
Brunswick has had no tenure line faculty
in Portuguese and is only this year that
Department is finally opening opening a
search but only for one position so I
didn't move to Northwestern University
where I have been teaching now for
almost 10 years a private and much
smaller elite University that to some
extent emphasizes professional degrees
and the sciences with some humanistic
training added in my department there is
practically no demand for majoring
Portuguese as the few students would
take Portuguese language rarely attained
proficiency beyond the intermediate
level and therefore literature courses
with readings in Portuguese are simply
out of the question so I had to adjust
and design an interdisciplinary minor in
Portuguese language and lose the phone
cultures in which some of the
requirements can be fulfilled with
courses in translations or from other
departments in fact the readings and
discussion in all of my courses are now
in English translation which is not
ideal but at least it is power
it is possible today partly thanks to
the translation subvention grants
offered by the biblioteca Nacional and I
hope that will continue still even - I
feel at Northwestern among other reasons
because this broad official who
abandoned us courses with a Brazil
company in order departments are almost
inexistent
in fact if I am not mistaken I think
that I am now the only Brazilian is in
the entire School of Arts and Sciences
perhaps even on campus
so again interdisciplinarity and
collaboration become a necessity but a
very welcome one I would say as it has
opened the study of Brazilian literature
and culture to students in a variety of
fields not only those closest to us such
as Spanish and comparative literature
but also to majors in fields such as
economics political science psychology
business journalism screen cultures etc
not to mention the student athletes who
were drawn at first by their interest in
soccer or capoeira I am frequently
pleasantly surprised as I realize that
these students do not want simply to
fulfill a general requirement in the
humanities but they actually find it
important to have a broad humanistic and
global education even with a course that
might be on Brazil which they often call
it a niche course so now let me say that
this not might not be viable in other
institutions with less resources perhaps
for even if I had very healthy
enrollments in many of my classes in
places such as northwestern and assume
of course in Princeton we are allowed to
run a class with five or sometimes even
less students and that's not the case in
particularly in state universities okay
so this is not the undergraduate level
on the gradual level I would say that in
spite of the discrepancy in resources
northwestern students are not so
different from those in the doctoral
programs at Rutgers and other research
universities most of them do not have a
doctorate
most of those universities do not have a
doctoral program exclusively in
Portuguese and I believe that in the
current situation it would be
unrealistic and perhaps irresponsible to
consider creating one and yet students
in my department which focus focus on
Latin America are always enthusiastic
about graduate courses on Brazil
- and many include a significant
residual component in their dissertation
they are required to learn Portuguese
and are very excited to do so but
whereas writing a dissertation
exclusively on Brazilian literature is
possible it is not encouraged unless the
student plans to return to Brazil which
seems more and more unlikely
in fact one thing that we should expect
and in which I have noticed in the last
two or three years is that the grad that
gradual applications from Brazilian
students might increase them
dramatically in any case both our
undergraduate and undergraduate level
both in teaching and research students
as well as faculty will always have to
reach out to other in unities and
disciplines and to color collaborate
more than ever for example at
Northwestern I co-direct an
interdisciplinary cluster called global
avant-garde and modernist studies a
growing field that has offered great
opportunity for the study of Brazilian
literature and our very unique
avant-garde movement some of my most
exciting collaborative projects have
been with the faculty in the French
department with whom I organized events
on modernism 1968 and so on another area
that is also promising is the visit of
Brazilian writer writers with some
support of the Creative Writing Program
for example this year we hosted a most
diverse group of 13 resilient poets
writers of fiction and graphic novelists
and this this year will weep and to
bring another five or six as part of a
program created by Luna del Toro's
leadership professor at the Sorbonne our
I also wanted to make sure that other
universities took advantage of that and
we created bridges for those writers to
some of those writers to butcher other
universities and as a result we are
publishing on a volume of short stories
and poetry by those writers
about Chicago the title would be another
gasps Chicago which comes out in April
and hopefully that would be translated
in English so so this kind of visit of
writers I think it's very important and
it stimulates these students and I
wanted to mention like Raja you know
when he was the consulate in different
places such as Chicago in San Francisco
he created a number of these writers in
residence programs that were very
exciting happy finally I want to point
out to the burgeoning fields of de colo
new theory and a renewed interest in
critical theories from the south as an
opportunity for introducing the works of
some of brazil's most important
intellectuals however he lecture is
still there is still need for
translations of the essays by classic as
well as contemporary thinkers something
which can be hardly be attained without
some sort of stood attention hi this is
de Brazil for example was just recently
translated and recently also there was
some collections by writings by Poli
middle Salas Gomez and in madalena shall
we
in short in spite of my pessimism I
still see some relatively promising
signs of growing interest in Brazilian
cultural studies as professors are
located not only in language and
literature departments but also in
programs or departments of Gender
Studies African American Studies
performance studies English comparative
literature art history and so on
having said that I perhaps others who
are here today have many more questions
than answers regarding potential
collaborations with bazillion scholars
and institutions and probably many more
questions than we had a few months ago
when we accepted the invitation to
participate in this event I for one
cannot help but wonder about the short
and long term effects of the statements
of the incoming Secretary of Education
whose preliminary agenda includes norms
for conservative society traditional
values associated with the
a vision of the family and humanistic
morality also and this may sound
controversial but I sometimes ask myself
how can we make a case for the study of
Brazilian literature and culture in
times when global warming and the
effects of deforestation are denied when
the rights of indigenous peoples are
threatened when social movements and
human rights are demonized and when
there are plans to erase even its events
from history in other words how can
Brazilian allusive only literary studies
or Portuguese language and literature
departments proved to be relevant next
to the subjects of anthropology
environmental sciences public health
social sciences law and even the
pressing work of my fellow historians or
even close to home home how can we
promote an argue for the study of
Brazilian literature as opposed to say
the monuments of French German Russian
Chinese or even Argentinian literary
traditions at any rate as Professor
David sugar mentioned yesterday it might
be that the road ahead will be bumpy and
I want to believe that after what seemed
unimaginable or what seemed unimaginable
occurred there is some value and urgency
in studying the words of our best
creative writers and how they have
responded to times of crisis skepticism
or even despair and perhaps today more
than ever it is urgent to better
understand the rules of rhetoric irony
dialogue fiction narrative storytelling
speech acts alternative truth etc and if
I came to illustrate that the Brazilian
literature is among the best thing in
the world I don't even know what that
would mean I feel encouraged as I
witness the emergence of a vibrant and
heterogeneous new generation of writers
and readers who in spite of everything
continue to make literature not only
relevant but also a mode of resistance
and even for some an alternative form of
solution
[Applause]
our next speaker is Professor Seth
Garfield from the University of Texas
Seth is noted scholar of the Amazonian
region as did an early book on
indigenous peoples in the Amazon and a
recent book on Brazil the United States
and the Amazonian region
and we'll also be speaking on history
Thank You Stuart I wanted to thank the
Brazilian Ministry of Education and
Council on Latin American high Buuren
studies for the opportunity to be here
and to participants wonderful panel
echoing what Dane said history is not a
discipline we're co-authored monographs
and articles are the norm but historical
research and sprints eclis relies on the
archival findings and methodological
innovations of previous and contemporary
scholars for revision and renewal in my
presentation today on the challenges of
research and Brazilian history the
United States I wanted to focus on three
themes all of which have been covered by
the other panelists so I'll echo or add
to what they've said first is access to
primary and secondary sources in Brazil
on Brazil second shifting trends in
Brazilian is historical scholarship from
an older tradition of comparative
history to a connective history and
third of the broader challenges to
encourage us students to study Brazilian
history and to study abroad in Brazil
and I'll try to reference both research
and teaching in my comments and also to
rely on personal experiences were
relevant first on the access to sources
I'll begin by stating the obvious which
Dean so wonderfully explicate 'add
digitization has been a boon for
Brazilian as historians in sharing their
scope their research with Brazilian
scholars and in keeping abreast with
dissertations and journal publications
in Brazil given the excellence and the
breadth of historical scholarship coming
out of Brazil much of it thankfully
available to Brazilian SVS CLO and the
digitization of doctoral theses in
Brazil Brazilian scholars have a robust
intellectual community to dialogue with
and
learn from and by the way one that has
broken out of the intellectual
traditional intellectual access of Rio
and San Paolo with the proliferation of
graduate programs in history throughout
Brazil in terms of access to primary
sources digitisation has also been a
godsend in particular the digitization
of old rare Portuguese language books of
Brazilian newspapers and journals and
archival materials has greatly
facilitated research and all sorts of
fields intellectual history history of
science environmental history political
history and cultural history I'm
thinking here aside from Google Books
and happy trust of the digitalized
collections of the Brazilian ministries
and provincial presidential reports from
the 19th century digitized by the center
for research libraries as de mentioned
with funding from the mellon Foundation
the digitized periodicals at the second
Austin Allen the Midland library for our
histories of political repression and
human rights in Brazil the website of
memorials that the Duda or the National
Security Archive of the United States
for environmental and indigenous history
the digitized collections of the
instituto sochi on bin tau in sao paulo
and just as a personal anecdote i did
research on my first book and at the
institute of socio been taught back in
the early 1990s and that in those days
it was called said g the center for a
Humana call or something and everything
of was there was no digitisation and on
my new project i need to consult that
archive and I'm still in that 1990s mode
and thought I had to go back to eg
innopolis to consult the archive and I
was told no you don't need to do that
everything is online now so it greatly
facilitates the type of work that we do
I would even go so far as to say that
digitization has enabled us to write
entirely new histories and by way of a
more specific example I'll touch briefly
on my current research project on the
history of guada na from pre-columbian
times through the 20th century
now despite being an indigenous cultivar
representative of a cultural forest or
anthropogenic landscapes in the Amazon
that Suzanne mentioned yesterday and
despite being the namesake of a
multi-billion dollar soft drink industry
a product of that industry and an icon
of brazilian national identity up there
with samba and football and Coca Cola's
nemesis of
we have no historical monograph in any
language I'm going enough and even in
comparative histories of stimulants and
drugs which would be another natural fit
because quod ona has the most caffeine
of any plant in the world quad and I
usually just receives a passing mention
now there are a number of explanations
for this but for now I'll merely
mentioned what was traditionally the
problem of sources unlike say coffee or
sugar gratin I never was a leading
exporter of Brazil it never relied on a
slave labor force whose economic value
and social control was a constant source
of concern for elites who left behind
historical materials and it never had
specialized government bureaus to
generate extensive paper trails but
although the documentation on wanton is
sparser and certainly more dispersed
digitization has allowed me to gain
access to a variety of sources in Brazil
in the United States to reconstruct this
history who would have known that when
thanks to digitization that in the 19th
century Brazilian statesmen who are very
much concerned with the destructive
impact of extractivism in Amazonia
looked to guada na which was cultivated
by small farmers both indigenous and
non-indigenous as the salvation for the
region what today we would call I guess
sustainable development and since guada
nas primary market was in not to grow so
via that Tapajos or than my data rivers
it was also seen as holding great
geopolitical importance in sustaining
transportation and trade links on
Brazil's sparsely populated western
frontier
thanks for the digitization of
anglo-american and medical and of
anglo-american
medical and pharmaceutical journals I
came to learn that guarana was once
quite the rage in North America that is
in the 1880s and 1890s when it was used
to treat sick headache nervous
exhaustion and other symptoms of
so-called neurasthenia and by the way
apparently Lizzie Borden the infamous or
supposed to murder of her parents
you know the axe after her daughter the
family doctor came to the house after
the murder she was given a patent
medicine which apparently contained or
supposedly contained guano so I guess
that would make
most famous or infamous 19th century
consumer that we know and thanks to the
digitisation of Brazilian journals I've
also been able to reconstruct how
advertisers and advertisements and
articles in popular magazines marketed
water now soda since the 1920s as a sign
of modernity for middle-class women of
respectability for men a source of
energy and comfort for children and of
course of fantasy for all now in terms
of undergraduate teaching idea that the
digitization of audio-visual materials
and primary sources takes the student
experience in Brazilian history to a
whole new level while they're seeing
paintings by Debray or the photographs
of mark phase or the propaganda films of
the office of inter-american Affairs or
clips from a telenovela this new dynamic
the sensory realm is so important and
effective in teaching and reaching
undergraduates but of course new
technologies bring new challenges for
undergraduate teaching the challenge is
to ensure that the analytical skills the
critical thinking and the writing that
are fundamental to the discipline of
history are strengthened rather than
submerged by the new digital based
learning methods the Internet is also
not eliminated inequalities and access
information as we all know and this is
true for historians as well not all
archival collections in Brazil are
digitized or fully digitized due to
problems with funding and staffing and
in general this gap I would imagine is
most vexing for social historians who
still must comb through unpublished
materials estate inventories or legal
cases or police records materials that
are often still not accessible on the
Internet historic research is always
laborious and it's even more so when
extended stays away from home are
required so the first Challenger go-live
list is committing funds to ensure
greater access to digitized materials
now this recommendation comes with a
caveat that digitization should not be
advanced at the expense of the
preservation or the destruction of
archival materials as supposed
cost-cutting measure measures as was
proposed in a recent congressional bill
in Brazil the so called key Medusa kilos
and indeed public commitment to the
safety of archives and it's our
collection in collections in Brazil must
be a priority the burning of the
National Museum and in Rio it's isn't
irreparable loss not only to Brazil's
historical patrimony but global
historical patrimony is a chilling
reminder second point concerns shifting
trends in Brazilians historical
scholarship from comparative to
connected histories there's a very rich
tradition in historiography of Brazil in
comparative histories the United States
particularly in the field of slavery and
abolition the most famous books Karl
degler is neither black nor white
slavery and race relations in Brazil the
United States which was published in
1971 it was the only book as far as I
know the Brazil related theme to win the
Pulitzer Prize in history comparative
studies of Brazil and the Knights have
not fallen completely out of fashion in
2014 victory six own who's a Brazilian
is starring at the FA assault about who
did his doctoral work in United States
published a book slavery and war on the
Americas race citizenship and State
Building in the United States and Brazil
which compares the u.s. Civil War and
the Paraguayan war but compared to this
we have taken a bit of a hit in part
because of its methodological challenges
its historiographical misalignments and
frankly its potential to perpetrate
generalizations or essentialized notions
of so-called national character as
evident in save yana Moog's
classic book mundane and she's APO
natives published in 1957 and then in
English translation in classroom
teaching the same assets or liabilities
can be attached the comparative angle on
the one hand the ability to generate
undergraduate interest in Brazil through
compare and contrast to the United
States on the other hand there's always
the danger of turning the United States
or Brazil into the other and or of
comparing apples and oranges in recent
years the emphasis in scholarship has
shifted more to connective histories
between Brazil United States thereby
brought on in our understanding of how
ideas and goods are exchanged between
the two countries and how relationships
of power are established contested or
Rhian scribed within and between the
nation states these conductive histories
help from many different specializations
diplomatic history commodity studies
histories of science and medicine
intellectual history histories of the
black diaspora and transnational
activism so just a few examples and this
is taking place both in Brazil in the
United States so in Brazil we have
Simoni crops work at fiocruz on the
influence of US medical
training on Brazilian cardiologists also
fiocruz ship after Hawkman's research an
influence of the Rockefeller Foundation
on public health campaigns in Brazil
Antonio Pedro tota scholarship on the
Americanization of Brazil during over
two and Cecelia aceveda's work on the
Peace Corps in Brazil for scholarship in
the United States we could point to his
cell soca studios new research project
on the reception of Uncle Tom's Cabin in
Brazil and Spanish America is that the
automotive out this recent dissertation
on the impact of the u.s. Civil War and
slave rebellions in Brazil Nicole
Siegel's book on the exchange of popular
musical forms and racial ideologies
between Brazil United States my own work
on history of US involvement in the
Amazon or or - and James Greene's work
on resistance the Brazilian military the
United States now turning for the last
point the broader challenges for
encouraging US students to study
Brazilian history and to study abroad in
Brazil there are a number of troubling
trends to report so I'll build here on
what both Dean and say sir said first
nationwide with the crisis in the
humanities there's been a steep drop in
undergraduate majors in history
according to an article in the Atlantic
the number of undergraduate majors in
history nationwide at all sorts of
universities is down about 45% from its
2007 peak and majors in Latin American
Studies and other areas studies have
also dropped since the economic crisis
of 2008 as students switch majors are
the assumptions that the skills that
they acquire in STEM fields will be more
lucrative or a marketable among the
casualties in the humanities has also
been enrollments in Portuguese language
classes according to a recent report of
the Modern Language Association between
2013 and 16 u.s. enrollment in languages
other than English fell 9.2 percent the
drop in Portuguese enrollment during
this produce 20.8% language teaches
language classes teach more than
Portuguese they teach about Brazilian
culture and moreover the type of
interaction that undergraduate students
have with their instructors and language
classes is more personal intensive and
sustained than most other liberal arts
classes so in this sense they have a
deep impact linguistic intellectual and
personal on students and if students are
not enrolled in Portuguese classes they
are deprived of these upper
so if you put together these trends that
drop in history of Latin American
Studies and in Portuguese language
instruction you can see the reduction of
the pool of undergraduate students who
have traditionally tended to study
abroad in Brazil and without proficiency
in Portuguese it is more difficult for
students to gain entry into PhD programs
in Brazilian history as Dan mentioned so
the recommendation here again would be
for a greater funding for Portuguese
language instruction now of course there
will always be students the United
States who are fluent or proficient in
Portuguese and who have personal
experience in Brazil and often these are
students whose parents have served as
businesspeople missionaries diplomats or
academics or are the children of
Brazilians or Brazilian Americans but
college should also also be about
enabling students to broaden their
intellectual horizons and for our
purposes today learning more about
Brazil and its history and culture I
know because I was not one of those
students whose parents had a connection
to Brazil I guess I was one of those
little Brazilian as' but as an LS major
yeah I had to take a minimum of a year
of Portuguese and this exposed me to the
language and nurtured a greater interest
in learning more about Brazil and with
funding from Yale I was able to travel
to Brazil the summer of my junior year
to conduct independent research from my
senior essay project on the Brazilian
Constituent Assembly and the rest was
history I was fortunate and I've made my
profession alive trying to give others
the chance to gain greater knowledge and
expertise in Brazilian studies but doing
so entails discussion of both the
opportunities and challenges in the road
ahead thank you
[Applause]
we now have some time for discussion and
questions or any questions for our
presenters
Browdy so i have a question that has to
do with the connection between work and
history and literature and other kinds
of priorities that perhaps exist within
the Brazilian government or within
Brazilian institutions
I found myself I'm also a historian I
found myself many times in in the last 5
or 10 years in a position where I'm the
only historian who's talking to groups
of people who do other things so the
historian an illegal history group or
the historian in an urban studies group
and the question that they're most
asking is why does it matter to have
history if what we really care about is
what's happening in the present tense
and I wonder if people on the panel
might be able to talk a little bit about
how not only the generation of history
in Brazil but also the relationship
between Brazilian historians and u.s.
historians allows us to understand
current day issues and conjectures more
effectively because I think that's one
of the most important justifications for
our discipline in a lot of people's eyes
whether or not we want to think of it
about it that way and for say sorry of
course the same the same issue having to
do with literary and cultural studies
that's a question for Stewart shorts
know at some level I mean although my
own research and most of my teaching is
on the 19th and 20th century really the
17th probably is is where I usually
start teaching I rarely teach ancient
history I take for granted that to know
the world it's better to have a 500 year
horizon at minimum that doesn't mean
that that helps to solve problems like a
problem in our neighborhood right now
about closing a major Avenue so that a
museum might be built and and how and
where traffic so they're there multitude
of problems that can probably be better
solved by by not worrying too much about
the 500 year
spective but the really important
problems things having to do with
identity with the Future III I think
simply are likely to be dealt with in
ignorance if you ignore what's already
happened so I take for granted that we
think better and think more wisely if we
have a 500 year horizon now my research
is often on 20 years stretches of time
that's something different but the
historical perspective that's I'd say
it's the it's the long one that's
interesting Stewart you have a yeah it
strikes me that that our meeting here
with its new emphasis on science which I
find is very interesting in a
proprietary involved and this is not
only something that's happening in in
Brazil or in other countries but it's
something right here at this university
as well the relative role of Humanities
Center and the sciences it strikes me
that if we want to promote more
scientific contact between the United
States and Brazil that American
scientists are going to need the
Portuguese language in in order to
operate efficiently in that in that
interchange and so I I don't find the
two things are necessarily in conflict
with each other that they ought to be
supporting each other in terms of the
long range history of Brazil I'm a
colonial historian and I think of some
of the major questions that have been
part of the Brazil's own study of itself
one of the major questions has been the
role of the state and its relationship
to society you know there are Brazilian
historians who argued that Brazil had a
had a state before I had a say it had a
society and that's a question that you
can find
and ramundo falfa otto and from in a
whole line of history and this is
something that it seems to me
preoccupies brazil at the current moment
and so there's some advantage in looking
at the in the long term and looking at
the way in which historians both
brazilians and those from abroad have
have viewed that a question like that
and other questions on race ethnicity
immigration etc all seem to benefit I
think from a view of the historical past
and the way history has has treated
those questions I me just say from
personal experience I recently was
involved in a project and I found a
Brazilian collaborator in my project at
the ebj and trained as a geographer but
who is a great specialist on entomology
on insects
it's a project about Salva in in Brazil
and the role that insects have played in
agriculture in the development of
agriculture in Brazil and so there was a
kind of accidentally an incidence of a
combination of somebody in the
humanities and somebody in the Natural
Sciences collaborating in a in a project
about Brazil with implications about the
present as well as as a history so from
my own personal experience I would think
that history has a role to play as the
development of the sciences both in this
university and in Brazil is taking place
chef just that well obviously um history
explains you know where we are today it
D naturalizes things that we take for
granted or as essential and shows their
change origins in time and it mobilizes
people because we're outraged with some
of the atrocities that took place in the
past and we're also encouraged or
heartened by some of the cards that our
ancestors have shown in moments of great
adversity so that's how I would answer
the the classic question that's
opposed to historians well in terms of
literary that is a which I mean I can
also my work is very historical very
much based on archives but I don't want
to generalize but perhaps literary
scholars particularly those that are
trained in the u.s. more than historians
I think I'm more comfortable asking
those questions in the book right or at
least the traditional hysteria Rafi
tries to be objective and and and for
literary scholars it's more effective
there is more effect involved in
questions so for example in my book
which is about literature in Brazil turn
of the 19th to the 20th century and it
is on the question of friendship in
Brazil and one of the questions that so
friendship and enmity so one of the
questions that are that the book asks is
that how is it that a nation like Brazil
came to understand which is clearly
divided racially socially ethnically
came to see itself as harmonious and
cordial and how those terms that we use
so I try to trace that through
literature in history and archives but
by reading so I think that more than
ever it seems that I mean to me it's
been very relevant to like an obstacle
everybody talks about how Brazil is
divided today and that's one of the
questions that I want to turn this night
thank you
well what I was going to say is it goes
exactly the line you were saying I think
you know in a way I was as I was
listening to the panel I was thinking of
people in the past that have traveled
from one country to the other
what escape from me is the best example
I come from the legal experience not to
scare of course the concept consider
comparative law the most important thing
in a world and in a way I guess
Tocqueville also did same when he came
to study United States and he went back
and both had some influence so
let's have difference in the world and
especially Montesquieu so the
comparative and I was gone I heard the
word connectivity instead of comparing
just pure comparison I don't I'm not
familiar with this difference but
whatever it is nowadays but the
connectivity that we have to
digitalization and other things I think
it's much easier to do that but all this
is a prio MOTU what I was going to say
which is I would be as a diplomat myself
is that I would be delighted if some
some day somebody would do a comparison
for instance of and going out to
literature
Mark Twain and Monteiro Lobato I've seen
both of them being reviewed nowadays
that whatever they said about it the gym
and her cover fit more chiona start
saying Montero but they were characters
that both country have maybe I don't
have to learn before not to do it the
same or to do something similar there
are experiences that have been exchanged
in two countries that have much in
common if the thing Brazilian United
States in many ways because of the pest
of indigenous populations and then the
immigration from Europe ended in the
shameful slavery and all that we had so
much in history to be compared or
connected to connected if you will that
I I would be as a reprobate I was asked
by a University of San Paulo last year
as a diplomat to write something about
and I heard the about the animal and his
book on comparing abundance and peony
rose and I was fascinated to see what
went through his mind I went to see how
how he got to start this comparison of
course many of the things he said at
that time especially the racial
questions probably not completely
outdated nowadays his opinions were
whatever did he said but there were
value at the time and so I think it is i
just fascinated to see how history and
literature could be helped as
Montesquieu used to say to for the
future there's no sense of comparing
just for comparing I mean unless you
want to take a lesson from that so you
know it's a challenge for historians and
comparative literature to read awry I
just want to hear any comments about it
thank you
well I say look the exact contemporary
of Mark Twain's actually machado de
assis and if you think of the humor of
Mark Twain you know an English literary
critic once said about Jane Austen that
the way to understand her is regulated
hatred that she's able to talk about her
sisters her mother the people around her
with brutal honesty but in a way that
they would find acceptable and that was
obviously much of Isis's approach to the
elite that he had risen into in which he
felt very much trapped you know what how
could someone like Machado be best
friends with someone like Jacques in
Nabucco without a certain kind of
regulated hatred love of the person and
then the the this is what says has just
written about friendship among man and
well strong awareness of how that person
became whom he became and how he had
become who he had become so Machado
obviously has that regulation down to a
very subtle version of English humor in
Mark Twain what apparently is open very
broad very colloquial Hume is in fact
deeply controlled and I think there's a
lot to learn about Machado and Mark
Twain by thinking about how each of them
mobilized humor and of course you know
masala ceased does mention the
Philippines American imperialism in the
Philippines one moment in Rome Casanova
Mark Twain living in the country he
lived in had to had to write about the
Philippines war Machado made a decision
to sort of drop out of partisan politics
at a certain point in his life so there
that that's where I think the similar
you know Monteiro Lobato
I think of an interesting but maybe a
more problematic comparison than than
then the Machado with with Mark Twain
but that ability to command the
folkloric and to turn it to political
purposes is is maybe the
the point of comparison but I mean
Assessors point was almost everyone who
does Brazilian literature in the United
States now is forced to become a
compared to us for career reasons like
it or not you do live easily spected and
you do junkie Mirage Xhosa jelly bean
salsa is a universe and yet you must do
jeonggi Mirage causa and one Truffaut
and Thomas Pynchon and so I'm not in
love with comparative literature I think
sometimes it's it has diluted and pushed
people who would do a good reading of
Brazilian literature off base you can do
comparative just by studying it you can
have a book on modulus that is
comparative in nature as camara did even
like back then that we would draw in
collection so I'm not just saying
compares and then there is space for ya
there is one Clarissa inspector that we
know that is let's say the Jewish
quality respect they start in Jewish
literature courses
that's one literature course we don't
want to make that the only Clarisse
inspector but but but it has happened
like you know I find that for example
the biography on her turn her to just
that and it raised any specificity of
her history in Brazil so it can happen
but I think it opens more possibilities
actually four debates for and again for
not only for comparisons in terms of
like looking for similarities but
understanding the construction of let's
say the construction of race is specific
to Brazil but it's not only specific to
Brazil it's there is a history so I
think what do we gain and what do we
lose by by thinking them that way all
the writers from Brazil that we studied
are wide readers which of them only
reads Portuguese literature Antonio
consciousness says that
Brazilian literature is by nature
comparative you cannot respond to your
comment I did not intend to deny the
value of comparative history and
particularly you know it forced us to
focus on the specificities our
commonalities in any historical
experience and all of us actually all
historians I think intrinsically are
comparative is because we're working on
people across different cultures and
centuries so we always have to fight
with that present is have no centric
impulse but I just you know but I was
focusing on was the sort of the
methodological challenges and also I
would say some of the sort of political
dangers of studies that really essential
eyes differences that are probably and
make assertions that are problematic to
sustain in terms of representativeness
of historical experience other questions
yes
yes but one which is deeply informed by
comparative context yeah hi well that
was a very informative conversation this
morning mostly though about Brazilian
studies in the United States and I'm
interested to know what's the status of
Brazilian studies that is research in
humanities in history in Brazil is that
getting stronger is it being corrupted
undermined is it and and is it
consequently increasingly a strength for
Brazilian studies work in the United
States or is it a constraint because
it's not contributing as much as it
should
I'm just interested in that that I guess
that's connectivity isn't it but what's
the feedback I I notice the the title of
the this whole whole conference is
Brazilian studies in the United States
but I I'd like to know more about how
Brazilian studies in Brazil feeds into
this if anybody is willing to comment on
that sure no it's like a whole new topic
but briefly just talking about the
discipline of history if I had a wish
list
I wish the conditions were better for
serious research on the United States
and Brazilian universities there been
good moves in that direction
unfortunately United States academia and
especially the field of United States
history is very heavily patrolled and
policed against outsiders in the name of
oh there you haven't read enough or in
the name of oh you're not quite
competent it's been very difficult for
Brazilians to come to the United States
and study the United States I've fought
with my US history colleagues I've joked
with them but the fact is that there's a
quiet not very permeable membrane around
around that field but that's not maybe
the most important history to learn I
mean what was said what Gilliland a
medieval historian historian of Brazil a
in interlocutor of mocs
aber what was he and so I can think of
specific reforms I might wish for in
Brazilian history departments that would
make their emphasis on Brazilian history
on national history sometimes even on
their civic history something that was
buttress by and accompanied with serious
consideration of the history of other
above other places you know I do work on
Japanese literature of I can't read
Japanese and have compared my shadow and
Natsume Soseki the Japanese writer I you
know I correspond with a student in in
in Asian languages at the University of
San Pablo who's trying to work on
sousuke and speaks Japanese you know
it's difficult but it's possible for a
talented eccentric student in Brazil to
get a very good education in European
history in Japanese history I wish it
were easier I just wish it were a little
bit easier for a not so exceptional
student to become a good student of
United States history and politics I
wish it were easier for a brazilian
student to to study japan because
there's so much of course to compare
between 19th century brazil and 19th
century japan
in 1959 when the field was sort of got a
reboost through the NDA grants it was
called lose a Brazilian so I wonder if
what the relationship is in teaching and
research and so forth in the fields of
history and literature with the so
called Lucifer Nia with the world of
Portuguese language which of course is
not a Latin American world but an
Atlantic
African and European and Asian world is
that what's going on is there any
possibility that you see there well you
know Thomas Skidmore said long ago that
that all of the people who were studying
Brazil the first generation really of
the Brazilian asst post-war we were all
basically via a philosophy though
because it was the Cuban Revolution that
generated an interest in the United
States government and really he probably
should have said we are the avocado
State Fidel and Julian because the
concern was that Brazil was going to
become the next Cuban Revolution and
thus the NDAA and fulbright-hays etc
programs stimulated the study of
Portuguese and really and I think the
people sort of my generation that's how
we got started and there are subsequent
generations that that have followed that
one of the problems with the decline in
the study of Portuguese I think is that
they should be more opportunities for
high school students
I've had many high school students who
spend a year in Brazil then come back
and whence they enter University they
are interested in Brazil and pursue
their studies I would like to see more
of that more exchange that though at the
high school level to generate more
interested in Brazil in this country but
I think is the importance of Brazil is a
world player should play a role in the
United States and and stimulating more
interest in the study of Portuguese
language and in ultimately in the study
of other areas of
of Brazil I think institutions like the
fundus Eritrea Vargas also have played
an important role in the study of the
social sciences in in Brazil and has a
role to continue to play and there have
been lots of good contacts between an
American scholarship and institutions
like the bargain foundation in Brazil
this is another place for for
opportunities I would just add to that
that that part of that same you should
have connectivity obviously I mean the
historic if you have Brazil in the
Atlantic world is huge going start
beyond Brazil in Spanish America so the
methods in turn shape the way historical
research evolves but also of course the
topics and so in my case the luzo
element enters in because you know
quantized first sort of exported to
Portugal and you have to look at all of
those connections to Portugal in the
18th and 19th century and that's where
the Luzhou part comes you know that
there are institutional things that
discourage Americans from going to
Portugal the Flass fellowship does not
allow you to study Portuguese Portuguese
but only only Brazilian Portuguese and I
you know the ignorance of well if if you
are focused on Heilig enero
you can't help knowing the Portuguese
presence in in in Brazil in some bottle
oh it's easy I think for an American not
to get it in bahia the Portuguese
presence is something more complicated
but I think that you get it that but but
there's very little incentive very
little stimulus to engagement with
Portuguese and in Lusso African scholars
I mean pardon me ma khyen say scholars
it's a little bit better in anthropology
than in history it's much better in
literature than in history but it's not
great in any of these fields oh I just
learned this morning Felipe that
we're so you we have a university now in
in Sierra that is bringing students from
Mozambique and Angola as well to Brazil
which i think is a very interesting
development remember she go barking
taught us that Brazil was only men so
forth about right and he wrote that song
in the the moment of political crisis in
in Brazil when at the time of the
Portuguese Revolution in the 1970s and
and Portugal look now is also going
through interesting changes itself and
the Portuguese have made a considerable
contribution to the study of Brazilian
history in what's called project risk
achi which was microfilming of all the
documents related to Brazil in
Portuguese archives then made available
through the various states of of Brazil
and and the project has has continued
and that is kind of leads into what Dane
mentioned about digitalization and the
availability now to do research research
without having to the expenses of the of
the travel and so continue contacts with
Portugal and and the presence of
Portugal in American Academy is also I
think an important aspect for the study
of the history of Brazil just one thing
in terms of I think that the term list
of onea
might can be helpful but it's not
necessary
so I think it will really depend I think
that in the United States it's more
useful than maybe in Brazil for Portugal
is certainly convenient in some ways it
grows in Peyer my experience as I also
work on Mozambique and I taught there
for a year is that when I got the
expecting to find similarities I found a
lot more differences that I found any
similarities it's I mean there was
interest in Brazil
from the Mozambicans there is a certain
historical interest in literature but it
was not even that there was even like
even in terms of literature people who
were stuff on African did it you'd like
to say that all the Sargent mother had
this influence maybe it really not in
Mozambique in Mozambique they would be
more interesting Garcia Marquez well we
have reached the our 11 o'clock and so
with record efficiency thank you for
attending
[Applause]
[Music]